kirk is going to start us off in denver
colorado kirk how can we help
hey dr john ken thanks for taking my
call you bet
so i have a question dr john about
dealing with feelings
of resentment and
basically i've been married for 10 years
we have two kids
and we have a wonderful marriage
relationship
and five years ago the business that i
started
moved from where we live about an hour
45 minutes two hours
away and so i've been commuting for
those
five years about 800 000 miles a week
and 20 hours a week and um
initially you know it was a gradual
thing we're gonna you know
move the business up there and then
we're going to you know grow it
and if it grows and if it happens well
everything went
according to plan and so now i'm in a
position where i've asked her
can we think about moving um last couple
years putting her ahead and the answer
is the resounding
no and so as we
as a as i drive every day on building
resentment
and so i telling everything that's the
death of our relationship
and you know it's a comparison thing
where every time she adds something to
her plate
whether that's you know um coaching or
something extracurricular
it asked me to come home earlier or to
ask me to
do something on the weekends that i
don't
necessarily want to do because of the
commute because of the yeah the issues
so um you said two things that that
contradict each other one is we've got
this beautiful relationship
and two i've got this this resentment
that is building
every mile down the road i get from my
house every time she says i need you to
come home early
which is a two-hour commute for you
there's something bigger going on here
than just this commute
what what is it
uh well i think it's that
she values i feel like she values other
things
um the reasons for her staying which is
her job
the kids where we want them to grow up
her family's here
over me and over my success and
my um grind that i'm doing and
so here here's the thing i don't think
that's necessarily that binary
but you have you are exactly right what
i'm gonna tell you is your
your marriage is on um red alert right
now
okay yeah you have made this into an
either or she is
i'm not she's forced you into an either
or it's not that
but um in the nerd world we call it
fundamental attribution air when you get
in somebody else's head and decide why
they're making the decisions they're
making or why they're not making the
decisions they're making
and then you go to war with your own
explanations of why somebody else is
doing whatever it is they're doing
so here's the thing your marriage is in
trouble
am i gonna mince words with you and you
again you can pipe any
you can't work two hours from your house
and commute every day
and be a present father and be a present
husband and at this point you're a
paycheck and a courier and that is
not that has no legs on a long-term
relationship
yeah here's what i would tell you kirk
uh you need to figure out what your
professional options are that might make
this better
and to what john said you are projecting
some
real feelings that you're having onto
her and i think you got to sit down and
say here's what i'm feeling
and let her say well that's not true but
have you considered that
when you ask her to move and uproot to
be closer to your work
that you are asking her to do some
things that she's afraid of
right and so she has some very real
feelings on the other side of this
reality so one reality is this makes it
better for you
and your life easier but that same
suggestion makes her feel like oh i
don't want to do that instead of hey we
got to be a big boy
and i'm going to tell you uh you need to
be the leader here you need to be
the person who puts your feelings aside
for a moment and get some facts
hey kirk let me ask you this what's more
important to you at this point
if i told you you gotta quit your job
today and find a job closer to home
or your marriage is gonna gonna end
my marriage of course there you go i
know you're gonna say that
so at some point you guys got to get
across the table from one another
at this point i'm gonna tell you i think
you should get a neutral third party i
think you guys need to go see somebody
and you all stop communicating and then
that when you stop communicating it
falls into an either or when it falls
into either or then it's you versus me
and now we've gone to war
and no marriage can survive that your
kids don't deserve that she didn't
deserve that man you don't deserve that
you deserve to be connected and loved
resentment
i think is the cancer that will almost
kill any relationship if it's not rooted
out so
get after this do what john said be a
big man about this come up with some
other options